maybe in in the in the in the tor
turlets
anything changing the turlets hello
everybody my name is markiplier and
welcome to the theater now this game is
based on a creepypasta made
a long time ago and if this game seems
familiar it's because i played
a game based on the very same
creepypasta and i still to this day
could not tell you what that story was
all about because the game was so trippy
and weird
but this one is remastered with better
graphics better detail
and more true to nature to the true
creepy factor of
this story of which i know next to
nothing about
hi oh oh it's a point and click
oh well oh ah 9-1-1
hello please please i need 4-1-1
operator no okay all right cogwheel
oh this looks cheerful this looks really
cheerful hello
hi i can go left and right but i won't
because i want to be polite
thank you please enjoy the movie
oh hey i will thank you sir
i oh ah
thank you please enjoy the movie
oh no i uh something tells me i'm stuck
in a time loop event or i really love
movies and this is day by day
okay oh this is not what i was expecting
oh good only good things happen in
bathrooms in horror games
hope i don't get piss in my eyes again
hello oh i don't like those me why am i
looking in those individual mirrors
that's
that's clearly not good okay that's
super weird
oh that's so weird oh hey what a
okay all right i guess i gotta check
these
individually because this is my job now
oh nothing
great you know that's that's real good
okay
all right well i did my inspection and
uh
i'll see you later oh hi diddly ho ho
how you doing what was it how's it going
in here
a whole lot of nothing huh
well oh i can't leave that's good
you know i didn't want to leave anyway
oh
hi hello oh that's not how physics works
oh never reach the other levels well
screw
you for trying to tell me what i'm
supposed to not do
hello okay looks like there's might
maybe be a movie here
okay thank you
please enjoy the movie i will
thank you no thank you sir thank you
you do the hard work around here i just
enjoy the place
oh boy okay
so what do i do it's just uh
the same thing over and over again it's
mildly disconcerting that nothing's
happening
okay all right do i just
do i just keep going do i just keep
going in a loop
thank you please enjoy the movie i think
this was part of the original story like
you were just stuck in a loop and then
then as you kept looping things got whoa
that's what i was talking about as you
get stuck in the door
i wanna watch i want to watch the movie
thank you don't whisper in my ear
okay let's go to the bathroom nope
apparently not okay let's go
oh okay no all right let's go enjoy the
movie then oh
all right totally fine
everything's fine oh oh
hum diddly ho ho we're we're we're all
good then
nothing's changed at all huh
everything's all the same
everything's all the same huh yeah
probably yeah totally definitely
this is cute thank you please enjoy the
movie no why don't you come in with me
man you work here all day you never
actually get to see the movie you always
get to hear it why don't you come on in
oh we can have a good time
hey take me up on that offer again you
want to come in and see this movie with
me
i know you do oh yeah you do okay
all right there everybody hey
hey barry how you doing please
enjoy the movie oh barry you're always
such a
such a lovely lovely lovely man
something must have changed right
something something had to have changed
maybe in in the in the in the turlets
anything change in the turlocks oh hey i
know
hey all right that's a little weird
i don't know why i'm looking at okay
[Applause]
well
well that was the thing
you still there all right alice get back
to wonderland
all right well that was that was
uncomfortable i mean i'd be shocked too
if someone walked in on me when i was
going to the bathroom but
a little uh a little overdramatic when
you say all right what else do i need to
do
what else do i need to find what else am
i gonna find
do i uh i don't have to go to the
bathroom again i've already pooped my
pants
so i think i'm good all good okay we're
all good here we're all good
i didn't expect that to be uh
interactable
ah
and what are we doing here
nothing oh is that me
why was i doing that or was there
someone else doing it on the other side
because one of those options is much
more concerning than the other one
all right now it's it's definitely
locked
wasn't before thank you please
enjoy the movie i mean as far as hells
go it's not that bad you just get to
watch a cool movie every night
and then you know you have to deal with
strange people in the bathroom but you
gotta do that
like anyway you always run into weirdos
and bathrooms just gotta go
thank you please enjoy the move thank
you please enjoy the movie i get it
what else am i supposed to do
i'm just gonna go for it i'm gonna go
for a mad sprint thank you please
enjoy the movie i will i will
i will i will i will
oh oh hey whoa no no
no uh what'd you do with the barry would
you
i can't do any oh yes i can hi
you don't have a neck never
reach the other levels
[Music]
okay all right then well i wasn't gonna
but now i want to
now i really want to enjoy the movie
you're welcome gotta support the local
theaters you know what i'm saying
oh wait wait oh oh yay i'm out of
oh thank you for that informational
blurb
thank you thank you
thank you thank you thank you please
enjoy the movie thank you thank you
thank you thank you all everyone is so
helpful in this theater
enjoy the movie i will i'm just assuming
if i just keep plowing forward like
straight through like portal
i'm gonna get to something that's
gonna be good for me
oh hey whoa wait whoa whoa i didn't want
it i didn't know i didn't want it until
it started happening
all right okay i'm i'm a brave boy
hey why why no don't do that no no no
no no no no no no no okay all right
oh this is the hallway of moaning
[Music]
denied there sure are a lot of scratches
on that door
that's moderately discouraging
but not that discouraging i'm not
discouraged enough to stop trying
i will uh persist until something
doth tell me not to persist by probably
killing
well i me even know
i was in a hurry i just i'm
inside this shadow lady ah
that's a problem hey i literally i was
standing right in
in you and i'm sorry were you in the
bathroom earlier that was not my fault
that was you should have locked the door
that's
normal i guess yeah normal
normal totally normal okay thank you
normal please
absolutely normal movie i will thank you
great this is going wunderbar
all right let's go back to the turn
whoa i didn't know you were having this
much
fun in here
[Music]
ringer okay ring around the that
okay that happened that was can i go to
the toilet
enjoy the movie a hero a hero if there
ever was one
maybe this is the movie maybe we're the
movie
is that what it is are we the movie
is that wait a minute hello oh
i see the view of the theater but i do i
dare to find a way down from up here
suicide might be a way out of this
so-called maze i'm stuck in but i'm not
ready for death
maybe i'm already dead maybe i'm stuck
in a certain stage of death and i have
to find a way to get to higher levels
but i was told very explicitly not to go
find higher levels that was that was
made very clear to me and if i am one
thing i am a
follower of rules i like rules i like
order
i do not like chaos and i want
everything to make sense
especially in my movie-going experience
thank you i just gotta go i've been
going on a complete loop for a while
there's gotta be something that's
changed right that's how
this works you change something i know
about it right
i find it with my eyes i lookie lou
and then i find thee lou right that's
how i go
god damn it damn you damn you
all right is that all you got huh you're
getting taller by the
by the encounter that we have and i
don't appreciate that
look look lady if you are a lady
i don't appreciate you intimidating me
with your height
ah hello hi
oh how nice
oh you're playing me soothing music
that's so nice oh it's getting
marginally less soothing
ah okay all right that's all right
that's thank you that's enough i will
not be leaving a tip
uh i'm gonna give you a two star on yelp
god i need to get a life please
all i'm doing is seeing movies what the
hell is happening to me
what am i doing i'm realizing i'm living
my life vicariously through movies and
i'm not actually living i gotta
that's that's all moral the story here
right i got i'm not living
my best life i'm i'm stuck in a loop
oh my brother i knew something was
happening anybody else huh anybody else
want to jump out
in the mirror i knew something was up i
knew it i knew something was up and you
set me on edge
for some [ __ ] reason i'm not
enjoying this movie as much as i thought
i would
i'm not nearly enjoying it as much as
you suggested it would be the trailers
really didn't say something about this
movie that i was really knowing about
oh enjoy the movie you know i'll enjoy
your movie i'll enjoy your movie all the
way to
your grave i'm going to enjoy your grave
that's what i'm gonna do i'm gonna make
a movie about your graveyard
thank you i really enjoy your movie
oh oh wait never mind i was fine i
didn't mean to complain like that
oh i'm fine actually i'm good with the
same movie i don't need another one i
was i was totally fine
with that so if you could just okay i oh
hey we're going to dramatic i'm the
creepy one here oh
wake up uh
no thank you if this is a dream i don't
ever want to wake up you
are a dreamboat and oh hey how's it how
do you do
thank you please enjoy the movie
thank you i will why are you the only
one that's subtitled because everyone
else
who talks to me or screams at me they
don't have their screams in subtitles
it's not at the bottom of the screen
it's just you enjoy the movie
i mean i'm trying to get any detail that
i possibly can out of this but it
doesn't seem like there's a lot of
detail to be had about this
is like it's the same thing over and
over again or you do you ever go home do
you have any other social life besides
this do you do you have any other thing
to your existence than this
environment that we're in please talk to
me enjoy the movie no i will
no you little scamp oh you know i will
i'm all about this movie
i'm all about oh no see again
i was fine this is like some kind of
test i can't even click towards you now
i can
hello you're still dreaming ah
wake up hmm
okay do you have anything action-packed
that'll really
you know smack me awake something
that'll really give me an adrenaline
rush the likes of which i've never
never seen before enjoy the movie
three seems to be the magic number for
things changing in this world so i'm
gonna assume that something's gonna
change
oh wow that's oh
hmm i have many questions about the
whole organization that you got here
what's uh no don't mind me i'm gonna
just explore the space
oh i like i like i like
wow what what wondrous world the world
of
art okay nothing great
why am i here hi
oh you're a movie man
think you're watching oh hi
i can do that too
you know when you run into someone in
the streets that you usually see
in like a store or something that's so
weird
seeing someone out of their normal place
in your existence is like oh [ __ ] you're
you have your own life
mr spinning head man
i guess i gotta go in the bathroom again
okay oh boy
i can't wait for the bathroom
oh hmm well
well well oh
wow
practicing your yodeling i see all right
well
okay cool yeah i i indeed it was pretty
good i'd give it a
solid b-minus please let me out
i just want to go home i don't know who
this weird swirly-faced man is
and i don't know what he has to do with
you and why you're trapped in here with
me
enjoy the movie i will thank you
please enjoy the movie thank you please
enjoy the movie
thank you please enjoy the movie please
enjoy the movie he said the thing
oh
oh no that that magical sheet oh it lost
all its magic
what's
all right well that was a little
unnecessary
thank you please enjoy the movie
wow wow yeah yeah hell yeah
oh yeah you hear that guys we're gonna
enjoy a movie
nothing's happened in a while i've
looped through many times
thank you nothing's changed i'm stuck
until i wake up
i gotta just wake up someday i'll wake
up
oh hey whoa take good easy there
did that mean some change or has nothing
changed or am i just stuck in a
perpetual loop again
thank you please enjoy
the movie please enjoy
the movie please enjoy the movie
please enjoy the movie and then the
chorus line comes out thank you
please enjoy the movie now the thank you
please enjoy the movie yes please enjoy
the movie
thank you please enjoy the music
oh oh [ __ ] oh you're open again
okay
oh well this is different than there's
that the whole string section deciding
to pluck
pluck behind my ears oh i can't do
hello okay that one's locked
it's like the bathroom stalls it's a
game of peek-a-boo
peek-a-boo okay last one peek-a-boo
i didn't want to play peek-a-boo i did
not want to play peek-a-boo i do not
want to be in this room and i did not
want to play peek-a-boo
i'm sorry i came in here i'm sorry i
want to go back to the movie
oh no oh no you know we don't need this
oh that's
oh that's awful oh no oh my god
okay hey
oh hi how
you good bro okay all right great
picture i took
oh that that that's a memory that's
gonna
trying to i'm trying to wake up but your
movie's so goddamn boring
i keep falling asleep so whose fault is
it really you don't even have a
concession stand in here
movie enjoy please thank you movie movie
please
enjoy okay never mind thought i saw
something
interactable oh hi
i'm sorry oh
okay
oh oh hi you got so tall
right thank you that was a little odd
but i'm okay with that because i saw
another person
and they looked lovely they looked
lovely they seemed to be playing a
computer game where they were
they were going to a theater and then
they were watching a movie over and over
again then they were stuck in the
theater forever and that's kind of
what's happening to me hey i was just
having a revelation here
you kind of possessed about 30 minutes
of my life and i feel like i uh
[Music]
yeah well then
my mind is always in a void of
nothingness sir
how dare you assume it was not my mind
is
emptier than a hole in the ground and
the longer i live the more i
dig that hole emptier and emptier it's
just an
empty void it's a vacuum of nothingness
but me screaming my own name
that's what i like it to be so don't you
try to change it
okay something must have changed
something
nothing ever changes up there nothing
except that note
oh i thought it was enough
bye
oh you want to be you don't be sassy
about this so i'm gonna be sad
i did not expect that to work
[Laughter]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Applause]
whoa i'm in a padded room
oh what am i waiting for
i don't know if i want to wake up i like
it better in the theater than in my
padded cell
okay i guess uh no answers for me i'm
trying to wake up i'm trying but it's so
hard i'm so tired i've been working
all day i'm just i want to come home and
i just want to see a nice movie
and i want to relax you're so you're
trying to stop me from being me
and i don't appreciate that i haven't
checked the bathroom in a while
that there's something cool nope okay
okay all right well then no more cheap
bathroom scares for me huh
what about the the phone scare boo no
okay all right well i guess i'll go what
what
what wha whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa
whoa thank you please enjoy the movie
i don't feel good when you don't say
that to me no no say it say the word
no say the words no
mary no
you have to say the word you have to say
the words to me barry
look i know i was rude to you but please
barry
oh the game just closed
no no
no i'm not done no
oh oh hi
oh that didn't look good
that looks that looks less than good
whatever that is
oh oh oh oh oh
no oh no oh no don't
okay all right well wow
okay wow that answered all of my
questions
i am so glad i went back in and saw that
there's
nothing here happening it's just okay
all right
wow that's just that's what it is okay
i'm not gonna
do that again that was that was weird
there's gotta be something else right
there's gotta be
i didn't get an answer i didn't see an
answer online there was no there was
nothing that anybody said
there's gotta be an answer right that
can't be it
that can't just be it oh no it's back
here it's back in the beginning
ah but what did i do wrong
what did i do wrong there's gotta be
something more
what did i do oh tell me
thank you what did i do wrong enjoy the
movie
oh what did i do wrong i'm playing
through the whole thing again and this
is actually a new
note i haven't seen this my mind starts
to develop at every walk through but
nothing else
changes i start to question the current
reality that surrounds me
it could be relatable or it could be
just a recurring nightmare
does that like does that point to the
thing about how i'm actually
you know playing through this over and
over again for
whoa it didn't do that
wow no whoa
whoa all right i'll come back once i
figure it out i am playing through it
again i
i literally am so i'm getting it
oh wait a minute wait this is new
it's just a brick wall but what does
that mean remain
calm i'm sure the magic pills
will help the magic pills though yeah
those usually help
let me just shove a couple of those down
my gob and see where it takes me
where are you gonna take me someplace
fun i hope
to the movies oh boy i love
movies i always enjoy them
or not okay hello
oh that's super weird
please enjoy the movie i will
okay thank you is there a point to all
this
oh my god oh my god i'm gonna lose my
mind
i'm gonna lose my gourd could i at least
just get some popcorn with this could i
please
please pretty please just get some
goddamn popcorn
a you who
oh how do you know my maiden name
what the hell oh yeah
thank you please enjoy
the movie i went to the ticket taker is
that what i was supposed to do
i you wait you mean i actually get to
see the movie
oh boy oh god where i can't click
nothing welcome to the show at the
selita theater
we ask for you to remain in your seat
and stay
quiet during the show i'll stay in the
halls break the rules
you shall be punished oh i want to be
punished
enjoy the movie oh i will oh you know i
will
okay oh boy
okay still excited
oh i love this movie i think
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Applause]
okay
is that the lady i saw in the room or is
that me is it supposed to be a
representation of me
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
uh-huh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh oh what lovely
art i do when you're on the magic
[Applause]
pills
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh no the horrible truth is revealed
the ticket taker was my doctor or is
that even still me i'm sure that's me
right
is that the horrible truth and so the
nightmares continue
did i not find the good ending how could
you find any ending
i don't understand was there a good or a
bad ending
was that just a bug when it crashed i'm
so confused
i'm so confused
i like it oh hey how's it going friendo
i like it a lot it was good
like it was a bit repetitive but that
was the point i wish it was just more
random
when i went through it again after the
crash it was very obvious that
everything was linear script but if it
was like
based on random events that occur like
whenever you could go somewhere and it's
like something happens and maybe some
people see some of it but
not everyone will see everything and
they have to play through it again and
there's like multiple endings depending
on what you see
that would have been really cool but it
was still cool nonetheless so that was
the theater
i had to go through it all over again
because of a bug but hey with these
indie games sometimes there's bugs and
you have to deal with it and you have to
just
deal with it as it is but this was still
good based off of a really cool
creepypasta that someday i will actually
read
or maybe not i won't but either way
thank you everybody so much for watching
let me know what you thought down in the
comments below
and as always i will see you in the next
video
[Music]
bye-bye
[Music]
you